[Music]
Opel's latest creation is the Crossland
x a subcompact crossover part SUV part
minivan it aims to combine the best of
both worlds
in other words generous space inside
with a fresh cutting edge look and the
cross land act certainly succeeds in
that octo a car testing Manawa Schaffer
mentions that the strongest growth is in
the B segment or small cars their sales
figures have doubled in the last four
years so car makers are scrambling to
roll out new B segment models opals
contribution is the Crossland X it
resembles its somewhat bigger brother
the mocha X but tones down the
sportiness and aggressive looks in
favour of greater practicality and
everyday driving we test-drove the
largest available engine the 1.2 liter
turbo gasoline with 96 kilowatts it
heaves the cross Lenox from 0 to 100
km/h in 9.1 seconds with a top speed of
260 kilometers per hour
[Music]
and mano-a-mano well explains that when
a car maker introduces a new model in a
segment they wanted to stand out from
its competitors Opel achieves this with
driver assists such as pedestrian
detection which the cross Lenox is the
first in its segment to offer
the front reveals the connection between
the mocha and the Crossland
opals logo is mounted on the grille
flanked by chrome winglets the embedded
low mounted fog lights emphasize its SUV
credentials the visible underbody
protection should do away with any
worries about scratch paint depending on
the trim level the colors of the side
mirrors and roof contrast with the rest
of the body
[Music]
a gently sloping roof contour recalls a
minivan LED tail lights are only offered
with the highest trim level the
selection as its called
[Music]
folding down the rear seats expands the
trunk volume from 410 to 1250 five
liters the interior gives a neat
impression many of the switches are set
on the steering wheel the 8 inch touch
infotainment system adds at least 650
euros to the price regardless of the
trim level air conditioning is standard
but automatic climate control only comes
with a selection line
[Music]
Opel is rolling out the Crossland X with
a range of five engines starting with a
1.2 liter gasoline engine with 60
kilowatts the most powerful though still
quiet fuel efficient is a 1.2 liter
turbo gasoline engine with 96 kilowatts
that's father Manuel describes the
Crossland axis suspension is offering
both comfort and sportiness though a bit
more comfort than sportiness he forgives
it slight tendency to roll the body sits
a little higher than normal
saying it's no problem and the car takes
curves nimbly and swiftly
[Music]
the Crossland X replaces the Mokka X as
the entry-level model for opals X range
the biggest model the Grande land X is
on its way
it will round off the x range at the
time prices for the cross flat x start
at just under 17,000 euros in Germany
but the 1.2 turbo edition we tested will
set you back at least 21 thousand euros
[Music]